Les régions ultrapériphériques sont des postes
avancés de l'Union européenne sur les trois océans.
La situation économique des RUP est fort préoccupante
parce que les RUP sont très éloignées du centre de l'Europe,
sont dans des situations environnementales et géographiques
parfois très compliquées,
et les marchés économiques sont restreints
d'où un fort taux de chômage
et des problèmes sociaux que tout cela génère.
Les régions ultrapériphériques sont des postes
avancés de l'Union européenne sur les trois océans.
L'Union européenne peut favoriser
le développement économique
d'abord par les aides qu'elle apporte.
Il faut effectivement permettre à ces régions
d'avoir un développement économique harmonieux
en permettant d'acquérir des infrastructures pérennes,
de rendre ces territoires plus accessibles,
donc une meilleure connectivité avec le monde
et singulièrement avec l'Europe,
en permettant aux jeunes de pouvoir trouver les formations
sur place pour ne pas avoir à émigrer.
Enfin, l'Europe peut aussi permettre
dans les régions ultrapériphériques
de se sentir pleinement européen
et non des citoyens de sous-zones.
La mesure phare : zone franche sociale
qui exonérerait de charges salariales et patronales
les 90% de petites et micro-entreprises que nous avons.
Un véritable partenariat avec les entreprises
pour qu’ils embauchent davantage et aider à la formation.
Merci l'Europe de soutenir financièrement et culturellement
les régions ultrapériphériques.